pimp my ride fans may have believed the
MTV show acted like a fairy godmother
for car lovers who couldn't afford
tricked-out rides peek under the hood of
this gearhead favorite however and
instead of finding a shiny v8 there
might be a hamster on a wheel there's no
arguing pip my rides popularity and
impact on palm culture but the show's
behind-the-scenes reality makes the show
seem more like a lemon many cars with
mechanical issues left with the same
problems there's nothing glamorous about
fixing a major mechanical issue and pimp
my ride apparently didn't try too hard
instead the crew seemed to use the cars
as elaborate advertisements for their
sponsored businesses by installing eye
catching fixtures some problems were
fixed but contestants have claimed labor
was sloppy while others reported the car
stopped working entirely days later one
contestant Seth Martino said in his
reddit AMA that his pimped car was a
polished turd and that he couldn't even
drive until he spent $1,700 of his own
money to replace the engine that the
crews neglected to work on but hey at
least he got a robot arm that can ding a
triangle for some reason check that out
I think it craved great job guys the
process took months the show gives the
impression that people got their cars
back days later the paint still wet but
some cars owner reported actually took
upwards of seven months shops had to
order parts or make custom details that
required time to top it off former
contestants told Huffington Post that
MTV didn't always provide an alternate
car for the entire time Seth Martino
told HuffPo that they only paid for a
rental for the first two months and
worse because of his young age most
reputable companies wouldn't even rent a
car to him
bogus back stories when contestants
didn't seem interesting enough the show
added some spice some cars were doctored
to look worse and the before shots
martina revealed in his AMA the
producers planted candy throughout his
car he wrote I know I'm fat but they
went the extra mile to make me look
extra fat by telling the world that I
kept candy all over my seat and floor
just in case I got hungry this begs the
question why humiliate a contestant on a
show with a guy who looks like this as a
regular cast member well apparently the
producers wanted a reason to install a
cotton candy machine first the cotton
candy machine didn't have a protective
hood Martino never even used it after
the shoot surprised the element of
surprise is great for good television
and pimp my ride always started with an
unexpected knock on a jalopy owners door
but how many do you really think he
answered at just the right moment that's
why car owners were prepped beforehand
some contestants knew that they were
finalists while others were already
miked up and ready for retakes
contestant Jay Glazer explained that
producers didn't think he seemed excited
enough so they made him do it again this
is what fake overreaction looks like
other times if a person's house didn't
seem right for television they'd go to a
different hall all together
for a show starring a guy named Xzibit
they sure did keep a bunch of weird
stuff under wraps on you need two things
you need these you officially been
pimped all right
chatting thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos at the one you just saw and leave
us a comment to let us know what you
thought was the sketchiest part of Pitt
my ride